Speaker 1: It just so happens that later this
week, just a couple of days after the Uvalde,
Texas, school shooting, the most deadly school
shootings since Sandy Hook in 2012, that happened
in Texas. And later this week, the National
Rifle Association, the largest and most powerful
gun rights lobby. What they mean is gun
manufacturers lobby. They work for the gun
manufacturers to sell as many guns as possible.
The NRA's having its convention in Houston, Texas.
The shooting happened in Texas. The NRA's having
its convention in Texas. And who is scheduled to
attend that convention? Well, Donald Trump
is scheduled to speak there and Ted Cruz is
scheduled to speak there. Republican Texas senator
and Greg Abbott is scheduled to speak there.
The Republican Texas governor just days after the
Uvalde Mass shooting. These three Republicans who
advocate for more guns in more places and say
guns aren't the problem and we need more guns,
they're going to show up and speak, presumably
in praise. Of the National Rifle Association,
which has been one of the most important
corporate organizations. That's what they are
at, putting more guns in more places,
making guns easier to access, easier to buy
and allowed in more places in American society.
How how do they do it? And what will they say?
How do they justify their presence there? How
do you justify the existence of the NRA in this
context? This is a celebration of guns. This
is a place that celebrates making it easy for
people to obtain firearms and just about
any type of firearm that they would want.
By the way, guns will not be allowed at Donald
Trump speech. They may also not be allowed at Greg
Abbott's speech. Now the of they always like
to say well that's secret services decision.
Okay. Well, needless to say, if guns make
everybody super safe, then why is it a
danger to anyone, even if it's Secret Service
saying we don't allow guns around the president?
If this is an organization premised on the notion
that more guns make people safe, you would think
the safest that the president would be would
be around a room full of people with guns,
because if any crazy bad guy with a gun thought to
do anything, there would be so many good guys with
guns there to stop him. Bizarre. All absolutely
bizarre. It's very strange also, by the way,
that when these events happen, all of a sudden
the NRA also goes to our thoughts and prayers and
all these different things. They're certainly not
going to bring up their role and making firearms
easier to access. And the cycle with the NRA is
as follows. And as I've said before, the NRA wins.
Whether there are lots of shootings or whether
there are not and here's the way it works.
It's actually genius in a way. If there's no mass
shootings for a while, which is like this is the
United States, there's always mass shootings,
but let's kind of qualify that by saying
if there is no mass shooting, that gets national
news for a week because there's mass shootings
basically every day in the United States. But if
we go a while without one of these major, quote,
major mass shootings like Buffalo, Sandy Hook or
more recently in Nevada, the gun rights people
will say it's thanks to guns. The reason that we
are not having that many mass shootings and what
means that many, by the way, it's a six standard,
but they'll say people are not going out and doing
mass shootings because they know. Others might
be armed. The shooters don't want to go out there
and have their plans foiled by a good guy with a
gun. Now, at the same time, they want to say that
the shooters are all simply mentally
ill. If they are simply mentally ill,
they're probably not rationally thinking, Well,
I shouldn't go and do a shooting because there
might be a good guy with a gun. Mentally ill
people, if you believe their story, wouldn't
be thinking that way. But regardless, if you have
fewer mass shootings, they say it's thanks to guns
if you start to see more mass shootings. Right.
They say this is a reminder. This is evidence
that everybody's got to be armed because it's
so dangerous out there. We need more firearms.
And then, of course, the classic is if there is
a mass shooting and there's a Democrat in the
White House like Joe Biden, the NRA will announce
Democrats and Joe Biden are coming for your guns.
Ted Cruz is already saying it. Others are already
saying it. They're coming for your guns, so you
damn well better get out there and buy some more
firearms. And then the gun manufacturers make
massive profits. The gun manufacturers
profit from mass shootings. There were
record gun sales under Obama after Sandy Hook.
Why? Well, it's dangerous out there. There was a
mass shooting, so you need guns to keep yourself
safe. And Barack Obama is going to try to take
your guns away. And then it is rinse, repeat,
rinse, repeat time and time again. So are Trump,
Cruz and or Abbott going to bail on speaking at
the NRA convention? I don't know. As of right now,
they're still scheduled to speak.
What will they say? I can only imagine